[Music]
in the desert
nothing is as it seems
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the dark of night
killers conceal themselves in plain
sight
in the end the sea of sand
death
comes from every direction
[Music]
[Music]
the arabian desert
a land of sand
rocks
and violet extremes
during the day temperatures can reach a
blistering 130 degrees
[Music]
few animals can survive for long
exposed in the open
but as the sun sets
and the heat dissipates
new dangers emerge
because night is when the desert's
deadliest inhabitants come out to feed
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
the ruble's fox
a predator adapted to an environment
where there is often more to hear
than see
[Music]
his large ears scan for sounds of prey
and they are so sensitive that they can
detect objects moving under the sand
[Music]
[Music]
cheeseman's gerbils the busybodies of
the desert
these energetic rodents spend the day in
protective barrels hiding from the
deadly sun
but at night they emerge to new dangers
growing to only five inches long
not including their tail
they are more vulnerable than most
but at night their instincts to dig is
overwhelming
some do it to uncover the entrance to
their homes
while others do it to scavenge for food
[Music]
but digging makes a lot of noise
and noise
invites danger
the ruble's fox is virtually silent
each little noise from the gerbils helps
him narrow in on his target
but these little diggers have attracted
another hunter
a killer even the fox decides to avoid
[Music]
arabian horn viper
a snake with venom that causes you to
bleed out
from the inside
she's an ambush hunter
and she's searching for the perfect
place to lay her trap
in an open chase with the gerbil she
doesn't stand a chance
instead
she finds a hiding place directly in
their path
she entombs herself in the sand
becoming a living landmine as she waits
for the gerbil to come just close enough
do
it's over in a blink of an eye
and a viper releases her victim
after delivering a deadly payload
the venom works by dissolving blood
vessels
causing a rush of internal bleeding
inducing fatal shock
even though snakes have one of the most
advanced chemical weapons in the animal
kingdom
her venom doesn't help when it's time to
actually swallow her kill
this is when she's most vulnerable
having to swallow her prey home
prevents her from using her only defense
mechanism
her fangs
[Music]
[Music]
it's all over in a matter of minutes
and with her belly full
she heads off to find a quiet place to
digest
sand geckos keep their distance
the coast looks clear
but it's hard to be sure
especially when you're a creature
without any eyelids
in a world of sand
[Music]
this arachnid doesn't have venom
but she doesn't need it
she has the largest jaws for size of any
arachnid
on a planet
[Applause]
she's a camel spider
and she's ready to kill
[Music]
something horrifying stalks a gecko in
the arabian desert
a camel spider
this eastern sand gekko holds his ground
but he's no match for
a camel spider
she crunches him in a death grip
while eviscerating him with powerful
vice-like things
as she eats she spits up digestive
juices liquefying her prey
[Music]
the rupaul's fox has seen enough
and returns to his own hunt
[Music]
but some prey is stranger than others
and even with his excellent hearing
the fox struggles to track a target is
always on the move
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
the juboa
a small rodent that navigates the dunes
by hopping around on two long back legs
uh
[Music]
[Music]
as swift as a fox might be
out on the dunes
the jaboa's two legs out maneuver is for
but the threat of death is not limited
to the ground
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
a pharaoh eagle
owl ruler of the desert skies
[Music]
he scans his surroundings for an easy
target
and with advanced night vision
he can practically see in the dark
and he detects something
[Music]
striped hyenas
not what he was hoping for
he has to keep looking
a spiny mouse
one of his favorite things to eat
[Music]
in the arabian desert
a spiny mouse is under attack from an
airborne killer
[Music]
with scavenging striped hyenas
patrolling nearby
the owl has to make quick work of his
midnight snack
[Music]
a view from the air provides a reminder
this desert is a graveyard
and scavengers like these darkling
beetles survive by consuming the flesh
of the dead
this corpse eater searches for another
pile of remains
but he's not the only one stalking the
land of the dead
the desert hedgehog
one of the sharpest predators in arabia
[Music]
but the beetle has a nasty check of his
sleeve
when threatened
he raises his abdomen
and expels a foul smelling liquid
the beetle makes a run for it
[Music]
but it takes more than a noxious defense
to keep a desert hedgehog away
[Music]
she routinely hunts venomous prey and
has developed a resistance to snake in
insect toxins
the graveyard attracts beetles for miles
and provides the hedgehog with an
all-you-can-eat beetle buffet
[Music]
this sleven sand gecko eyes another
crunchy desert snack
crickets
[Music]
[Music]
in this air drain the crickets are not
only food
their bodily fluids are his only source
of hydration
[Music]
[Music]
in a world of little cover
some predators have learned that the
best way to sneak up on your prey
is to swim beneath the sand
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but luckily for the gecko
this predator is not after
reptiles this
is a sandfish
a lizard who swims beneath the dunes to
sneak up on insects
like these crickets
the gecko
has found some competition
uh
[Music]
in tonight's race the gecko comes out on
top
[Music]
but his victory might be short-lived
unknown to him
a master of the sand had been watching
and waiting
[Applause]
[Music]
in a hostile arabian desert
a hidden danger emerges from the sand
the arabian sand boa
a few sea until it's too late
but by surfacing to feed
he exposes himself
to a fearless snake huntress
[Music]
she might look like a kitten
but she's a lethal hunter
and sanborn knows it
she's a sand cat
and is not to be taken like me
her target disappears beneath the dunes
[Music]
but she won't go hungry
[Music]
she's such a successful hunter
that she stores surplus kills for lean
times
[Music]
but this fearless little feline hears
something on the move
and she rarely passes up a chance to
kill
even a desert locust
but with its wings and powerful legs it
can quickly spring away from threats
to catch a locust
it's best to go
unseen
[Music]
one of the greatest locust hunters in
the desert
knows how to hide
in plain sight
the world of the fat tailed scorpion
is better viewed in uv light
researchers believe scorpions use
ultraviolet light to hunt prey
in the glow of the moon
with a venomous stinger powerful enough
to kill a human
she is more than a match for locust
if she can catch up
close
but not close enough
with a heavily armored exoskeleton
she's not built for the chase
it's time for a change of strategy
she tucks into the shadows of a camel
bone
waiting for the perfect moment to ambush
an unsuspecting passerby
[Music]
to the scorpion few targets are as
choice as the webbed footed gecko
[Music]
but without the element of surprise
there is no use attacking
a cricket
not as fast as a locust
but just as delicious
[Music]
a scorpion's eating habits are as
extreme as their habitat
in one night
she can devour up to a third of her body
weight
and not eat again for up to 12 months
[Music]
despite her deadly reputation
she has no idea what she's about to face
[Music]
she walks right into the crosshairs
of a saw scaled viper
[Music]
[Music]
and only one is going to come out alive
two violent assassins prepare to clash
only one
will survive
[Music]
with sunrise only two hours away
some creatures struggle to survive till
the morning light
others hurry to take advantage of the
remaining darkness
eager to kill
the still hungry ripples fox returns to
familiar hunting grounds
and on
these cheeseman gerbils will retreat
back to their burrells
giving the fox
the moment he's been waiting for
success at last
but his work is not done
he stores his catch beneath the sand
so he can continue the slaughter
so
others watch as the fox adds body after
body to this desert mass grave
[Music]
including a few who would happily rob it
[Music]
the fox smells a nearby wonder gecko
who would provide a nice bit of variety
to his turbo feast
[Music]
um
following its gnomes closer
and closer
exposed in the open
this slow-moving gecko doesn't stand a
chance against a swift footed fox
his desperation drives him into a
territory so dangerous
that even the fox won't follow
a place populated by the deadliest
predators on the planet
on the hot sands of the arabian desert
a rupaul's fox chases a gecko into the
lair
of the world's most dangerous animal
with half an hour to sunrise they've
wandered into the terrain of a strange
new species
that is encroaching on the desert
these are the deadliest predators on the
planet
humans
[Music]
the wonder gecko has to choose
turn back and face the fox
across this desert highway
[Music]
the gecko's not the first to face this
deadly crossing
[Music]
see
[Music]
his luck holds out
and it looks like he'll live to see
another dawn
[Applause]
for many of the creatures of the arabian
desert
the final challenge of the night
is finding shelter
from the oncoming sun
a danger almost none can escape from
in the open
[Music]
this arabian web-footed sand gekko heads
for a fallen log
unaware with lies and weight
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
the log the gecko hoped would provide
safety from the sun
is now his grave
as he falls victim to a centipede
with the rising of the sun
another deadly night comes to its end
[Music]
but for those who survive until dawn
it's nothing compared to the heat
they're about to face
a killer
you cannot
escape
[Music]
[Music]
you